hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to where is my hammer but my
hammer is right there obviously and I
can do this with my hammer up whoa odd
okay didn't mean to do that okay
I broke game didn't mean to excuse you
sorry Wow I do that holy hell that's
awesome
so this is a simple game that was made
in the game jam a while ago oh okay I
get it
oh that makes more sense BAM okay
middle mouse to switch left mouse to
slam right Mouse jar okay that marks for
sex hi teacher her blood here's my
homework yeah bit blip-blip blip-blip
blip-blip blip-blip a blablabla huh
okay so this game just takes advantage
of the unreal engines destructible
physics stuff and it's really not much
more to it than that there's it's just a
destroy game but it's a wonderful stress
reliever this game is completely free so
if you want to pick it up and just have
some fun
whacking things oh sorry excuse me honey
I'm home
Oh priceless art it deserves to be
slammed with my hammer oh why didn't
even get to slam it ah how about you you
want a good slamming how about a
horizontal slamming I didn't even do
nothing the guy in the crotch anyway Oh
God
okay wait wait wait wait oh my goodness
okay they seem to found the way to speak
to her okay Undine hi
okay then I'm in the roof now oh look
more priceless heart wiggle wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle good news we go
here we go eagle eagle you lose you lose
I missed how did I miss those right in
front of me Haley and it stopped missing
back are you going Oh lovely how have
you punk
well I'm like good oh wait I got him
don't do that again don't do that again
I get stuck in a loop the hammer gets
stuck in the ground and it just goes
everywhere head head head Flynn Blair
I'm doing a lot of our involuntary home
improvement here right oh boy bunk beds
rupees I did not do that I didn't do
jack I did all this I definitely didn't
do any of that
okay I'm not dying wait on dying again
the point of me playing this game is it
I love the concept of it there's no
other point besides just utter chaos and
rampaging but there's something about
like the inherent silliness of what
video games are all about it's just do
nothing I didn't do a damn thing you you
you owe you but anyway like the inherent
thing about video games is it you just
play them to escape a little bit of the
monotony and the fact that I can just go
around there's a game literally meant to
go around hitting things with a hammer
and that's it and they break and it
breaks beautifully it's awesome like the
fact that this exists is amazing and
it's totally free it was made in the
game jam in about 24 hours if you
couldn't tell but it's just fun
oh crap buh-buh-buh-buh-buh ah dammit
later that tombstone on the ceiling I'm
gonna show you who's boss the house
owner gets for dying hello car go put a
damn it we gotta get top okay oh I'm
gonna go and get your gun
perfect all right I mean the cool thing
about this destruction engine is just
that everything can fracture into little
edu bits even damn it
whoa I'm surfing I think I was surfing
cool oh god damn it where am I going now
ah Bob eh yeah I've had a good day
Dave's been a really good day I've been
having a lot of fun playing but I
actually really really enjoy like I just
got done playing action Hank which is
super super fun and then I stumbled
across this game and it's just like it's
just it's just meant to be fun
whoa and I really hope you're having a
good day too so if you need a little
stress reliever smashing up some stuff
with a hammer why not try this game
links in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you're having a wonderful day and
if not I hope this one makes a little
better thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
No
all right let's go oh my god I did not
do that fresco
oh no the kill designator got it
No